As you saw before, the distribution of ages of students taking Udacity courses
is positively skewed, with small students being younger than older. Here's
another example of a positively skewed distribution. Where you can see that most
values are on the left side than on the right. This is a distribution of income
in the United States in 2005. You can see here is says 98% of households have a
household income of less than 250,000. And it looks like the highest frequency
of household income is even less than 25,000 a year. What can we say about this
distribution? Can we say that it's symmetrical? The most common household income
is less than 25,000 per year. Most households make less than 100,000. Or
finally, no households have an income greater than 250,000.